[Musique]
quand vous connais au south up ou koné
moussa où ça va
malade à la baisse nos sportifs
musiciens et élus du département sont à
cape town pour le célèbre ou challenge
dix mille coureurs qui traverse la ville
sur les traces de l'australie au malaga
zidane tabarez 70 ses cols blancs bien
comme ça remise de ça
salt et france ô le résultat de cette
belle coopération a été travaillé il ya
déjà un an et aujourd'hui c'est la
concrétisation donc d'un projet de
coopération culturel et sportif dans le
cadre aussi d'un retour d'une équipe
d'afrique du sud pour la réunion au mois
de décembre dans le cadre de la
commémoration des cent soixante dix ans
de l'impression d' esclavage pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la veille de la course groupe lindigo a
fait le lien entre les peuples pour eux
pas besoin de parler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès les premières notes
tous se ressemblent les mots sonnent car
la culture et comme ils vont de l'avant
sera pas aussi sur le point de vue
relation faire le mélange le mélange
ensemble challenge amy winehouse est
direct et me pense demain demain devant
lui mais personne ne voit que ça va
donner
et notre vie sera sommes un peu tout le
monde sait le coût lié à un seul langage
ce soit fier d'être revenu cela fait
d'être créée ça fait venir à la réunion
aussi nul en liberté il y avait une
commune v n'est pas partout de la
science du vivant comme ça et là nous on
allait bientôt delahousse à neuville
voit bien que ça en attendant la course
la musique est ici le vecteur idéal de
communion encore plus pendant l'année
anniversaire de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
[Musique]
je